[Music]
the storm of the century
is closing in
it's happening
we are proceeding inbound to dorian
more intense than any atlantic storm
ever recorded
holy
that part of the wall is gone
this
is hurricane dorian
as storms hit new extremes and defy
prediction
national geographic gave cameras to more
than a thousand marine workers
to film wherever storms might strike
right around the globe
on a scale never seen before
this is what came back from our cameras
caught in the path of hurricane dorian
the fiercest atlantic hurricane
in history
[Music]
just your standard vhf radio
and
this is the marine forecast this is the
main thing we listen to when we're out
it's deep into hurricane season
ron yao is starting out on a regular
10-day trip on his shrimp boat sea king
taking with him one of our cameras
we are shrimping offshore of saint
augustine beach
and this is what it's looking like
outside right now which isn't so bad
out in the atlantic
a buildup of storm clouds watched by
weather satellites has begun to grow
as its winds hit 40 miles per hour it's
classed as a tropical storm
and is given a name
dorian
we're just going to keep an eye on it
and hope for the best
that's what we're doing we're not
waiting we got to go fishing boats ready
we're fueled up everything's
green light for goat
sea king is one of hundreds of vessels
now off florida's atlantic coast that
have taken our cameras to sea
as they keep watch on the new storm
you see that's the topical storm dorian
you can see that
the wind has changed
one of them is container ship summers
isles
it's predicted to be coming
quite bad in the coming days
tropical storm dorian is now bearing
down on barbados
where another camera is rolling on board
the tug pelican ii
[Music]
all right the weather is deteriorating
already this is a bit more choppy than
usual
instead of coming from an easterly
direction which is from that direction
the wind is now coming from
southeasterly direction
welcome to sunny barbados
for a tropical storm to develop into a
hurricane
a warm ocean is
vital when temperatures top 79 degrees
conditions are ripe
by late summer the sun's effect is at
its peak
and this year from florida to the
caribbean the sea temperature is hitting
a record high the water's 83 and i'm
sure by the bahamas it's in the mid to
upper 80s there's plenty of you know
warm water
that's what sets it off for now the
gasoline for storm
as dorian draws energy from the
superheated ocean
its threat level
is rising
we just wish that it don't come here two
years ago
when we got hurricane irma we lost about
half of our lobster gear
and now with dorian coming as big as it
is you know we probably lose 100 if we
had a direct hit
all right south florida we are tracking
what is now hurricane dorian hitting
full hurricane strength with 75 mile per
hour winds dorian crashes into the u.s
virgin islands
within hours wind speeds hit a new high
of 85 miles per hour
dorian is growing stronger
and bearing down on florida at 300 miles
a day
all right we're the only game in town
today
so we're the recco mission
heading out to hurricane dorian
in florida
flight noah 4-2 is moments from takeoff
blindside i'm ready
this is america's primary asset in
forecasting how a storm will behave the
p3 hurricane hunter
an airborne weather station that flies
right into the
storm taking with it
one of our cameras
we march into the storm
and we directly measure
things that can't be measured any other
way 242 on departure turn left heading
180 runway 2-7 cliff take off
their mission is to fly through the eye
to pinpoint dorian's exact center
and gather data essential for forecast
accuracy
radio sensors dropped from the plane
called sondes
are the only way to get vital readings
from inside a storm
good course good speed
after three hours airborne the target is
in sight
so is that dorian out there at 10
o'clock
that it would be
[Music]
about 10 more miles
we'll get stood up on the line
[Music]
and we're going to try to find the eye
of the storm
inside 30 seconds
roger 30. see about what's coming up
[Applause]
10 seconds
the wind speeds start to come up
we get bumped around a fair bit
and then
you start to hit the eye wall
here we go here we go
which is essentially this wall of
precipitation
the eye wall is where a hurricane's
winds are at their most powerful
one of the motors is right out my window
and the rain
is so intense
that i can't see the motor and it's not
a meter out my window
it's phenomenal
the rain impacts the propeller with so
much force it pits the metal
once we're inside of the eye wall
we actually follow the winds and when
they get to zero knots
that is the center yep
we're going into it now
[Music]
the most critical thing of every mission
is fixing the center
center and the turbulence
when we do
we drop the sun
release on
zonda's away
[Music]
[Applause]
steady on zero four
five and
every successive drop recorded lower
pressure three
two
one
which clearly highlighted to us that
dorian was intensifying really son
the flight's data is beamed straight to
the national hurricane center
where the new information confirms that
the threat from dorian is escalating
and we're forecasting dorian to go on
and become a major hurricane now within
the next 24 hours
that's category three four five on the
safra simpson hurricane wind scale
at category four a hurricane's potential
for destruction
is 200 times greater than at category 1.
and as it advances across the ocean the
prospect of dorian making landfall looks
ever more certain
talking about the life-threatening storm
surge and winds in the northwestern
bahamas the potential for devastating
winds and storm surge along the florida
east coast a potentially catastrophic
hurricane event in portions of the
bahamas in florida
all right let me put this on video
off florida's east coast fishermen are
on guard for any change in the weather
they're among hundreds of marine workers
using our cameras to capture tropical
storms whenever and wherever they appear
we got hurricane dorian coming this way
be here
saturday night
[Music]
in the atlantic
the biggest storm for decades is
building fast
rapid intensification sees dorian leap
in less than 24 hours from a category 2
hurricane to category 4.
directly in its path the island of great
abaco in the northwest bahamas
and beyond that
florida and the port of miami
the busiest cruise ship terminal in the
world and a vital hub for freight
okay
good morning everyone this is captain
bertian thanks for uh for joining us
here on the phone
responsibility for the port's safety
rests with the u.s coast guard under
sector miami's commander captain joanne
birdian just took a look at the 1100
update
for hurricane dorian and it looks like
uh anticipating
the first arrival of storm force winds
sometime overnight saturday late
saturday early sunday morning
a hurricane strike on a port can be
catastrophic doing damage valued at
billions of dollars
the ultimate precaution is to evacuate
the port and shut it down
we talk a lot about port closure but
it's a balancing act
to preserve the safety of the men and
women who live and work here
with
efficient maritime commerce
one day's closure has an impact on
florida's economy of over 100 million
dollars
my position here
as the cap of the port and as the sector
commander is
that safety is paramount captain the
port has ordered port condition x-ray be
set at noon today
all ocean-going commercial vessels
greater than 500 growth tons must
prepare to depart the ports and
anchorages
port condition x-ray is the trigger all
right thank you let's roll
for evacuation
all right guys
let's go to see
leading to complete closure of the port
all ships will head to sea to escape the
storm
while there's still time
as dorian's threat increases the
decision to close port miami
is followed by ports further north
in port canaveral
all boats are ordered to leave
all right
port's making us get out we got a cat
floor coming breathing down our necks
one of our cameras is with fisherman
matt beedle
captain with commercial fishing fleet
wild ocean
i mean the wild ocean fleet
tinny sue
mislin myself going into what they call
a barge canal they used to use it to
haul
coal and everything to the power plant
up in titusville i don't try and get
tied up and hunker down
while large ships must head out to sea
smaller boats can seek shelter inland
but some can be reluctant to quit while
they could still be fishing we've got
other boats in the port that are
supposed to be going with us
and they play the game of oh we're not
going yet and if they can't get out of
the port
the port finds him 30 thousand dollars a
day plus if you leave your boat up here
if it breaks loose and does any damage
to anything or any other boats you are
responsible and you are going to pay out
your butt
herb i guess i'll just go in front of
you
the wild ocean fleet will meet to tie up
at a mooring they've used in previous
storms
this is the most boats i've seen up here
ever for a storm
i ain't never seen boats up here like
this before
all these people have got their boats on
the south side that is the worst place
you want to be on
the problem with it is
it's going to be north and east winds
it's going to be at the back of their
boats not at the bow of the boats it's
going to spin those sumbitches around
and put more stress on their lines than
anything
sean i'm gonna pass you on your port
side and turn around put my nose into
the wind
on the north shore
the boats are lashed together throwing
that for increased stability throw that
line
tighten the bow line it's probably
already on the beach now
you're on the beach
category 4 hurricane dorian is now
entering an ominous new phase
seen from space
it's like a monster waking
as dorian
opens its eyes
a circular clearing at its center is a
sign of a well-established storm
with the strength to go on growing
in the next 24 hours
hurricane dorian will make history
in a way
no one
could have
anticipated september 1st
2019.
prepping for the hurricane
highest ground in hatteras is inside of
a truck
don't put a money it's put like 6 56.
ain't nothing happening now it's just
that win
some rain nothing too crazy yet
is really good right now
shrimp are very plentiful
shame the storm's coming on our part
8 a.m
dorian is flexing its muscles
winds have been bumped up to 160 miles
per hour hurricane hunters flew through
there and found some stronger winds some
lower pressure as well so they upgraded
it bearing down on the island of great
abaco dorian's power intensifies
in three
mighty steps
with the eye five miles from the island
its winds leap to 185
miles per hour
185 mile per hour winds we could see
gusts up to 220 miles per hour we've
never seen that before so this is a
historical event that is unfolding right
before our eyes
in the hours before impact
dorian has intensified at a rate never
observed before in a storm so strong
the ocean's already huge here
and the storm's
so far away
praying for those people in the bahamas
[Music]
okay john is now 11
52. like doing just picked up
on like a lot a lot a lot
and
it started to scare me now
just before noon sunday september 1st
dorian slams into the island of great
abaco
to become the most powerful hurricane
ever to hit the bahamas
[Music]
it's uh 12 o'clock and
stuff's definitely starting to come
apart all the coconut trees have snapped
off dorian's extreme winds gust to a
strength only experienced inside a
tornado
the intense pounding is prolonged by
dorian's slow speed of travel across the
island look at that
open ocean coming across from the
parking lot the street
to the marina
dorian's winds have pushed a 20-foot
wall of water on shore
we're standing right here
the apartment building
as we stay in though the whole roof came
off
please pray for us please pray for us
everyone please pray for us
by mid-afternoon the eye is here
dorian's eye is now over the town of
marsh harbor
an opening in the clouds 17 miles wide
but dorian's assault on the northwest
bahamas
is just getting started
good afternoon admiral joe birdian um
we're commencing our 24-hour imt in
anticipation of tropical storm force
winds arriving within the aor overnight
tonight so i have plenty of questions
thanks joe in miami coast guard hq
captain birdian's incident management
team is briefing all units in the sector
do we have anyone from the bahamas
online
okay
here we go here we go
go we are proceeding and bound to dorian
the hurricane hunter noah 4-2 is on its
12th mission into the eye of dorian
dorian you've changed
that's such a different story
dorian's eye has opened wide
there's a grand bahamas sized hole in
this wall
a stadium of cloud now 23 miles across
it's ugly
three
two
one release my points on
your science equipment is go
what they discover is a hammer blow
as dorian reaches the island of grand
bahama a very unfortunate place to stall
its westward movement
has stopped
[Music]
the most powerful atlantic hurricane to
make land fall has stalled over
northwest bahamas most populated island
if storm moving at a normal speed at
that intensity is going to be
devastating to have a storm basically
sit over the same general area is about
the worst type of scenario you could
imagine for those areas in terms of the
impacts
[Music]
this is what's left of the resort
and there's some of the boats that were
in the marina
for 36 hours
dorian has subjected the bahamas to the
most prolonged and powerful battering of
a populated place ever recorded
it's difficult to fly over these these
areas and look down at the devastation
to see the the level of violence that
these storms can exert on the surface of
the earth and suffering that the the
people that are on the ground
but we got to get over it because our
focus is the current
observation and how that translates into
protecting people in the coming days for
this particular storm
it's a challenge it's a challenge
at this point in time we're forecasting
dorian to move north northwestward
moving just offshore of the florida east
coast all the way up to north carolina
so the impacts are going to be over a
very large area now
as soon as you get it to him thing get
it on there and get that tied off and
get that bow line
dorian is now heading for the east coast
of the u.s
in mayport sea king's captain ron is
alive to the growing danger
well with the storm coming the wind's
going to be out hard at the north the
northeast i'm wanting to
get my bow headed up into it
storms are very unpredictable i'm not
endangering anyone for money it's not
worth it to me
it's just crazy out here man it's
on the fishing boat gooch off north
carolina the spreading anxiety is
captured on camera
lightning coming this way y'all wanted a
documentary
you're getting it as real as it did
it's it's
do or die now we're cleaning all of our
product and freezing it so
we don't lose it
hatteras on the outer banks of north
carolina is on a countdown to collision
with dorian
at jeffrey's seafood
brothers taylor and kelsey aiken handle
distribution for a number of fishing
boats on the island
trying to get all of our fish out of
here
they'll be paid for it and we'll make
money on it so
at least we'll be able to get something
out of this ahead of the storm anyway
a mandatory evacuation comes into effect
later today
they need to get as much of their fish
as they can on the last truck out
we were able to get all of our fresh
products out on the truck but we had
twenty thousand dollars worth of product
in our freezer that we had to
you know hold on to
the risk now is storm surge and with it
power outage and flooding the freezer is
just a few feet above the ocean if it
blows
35 40 50 miles an hour out of the
northwest all that water from across the
sound will come here and it'll flood
that's what happened the previous years
when matthew came
this right here
that's how high it was in here
in hurricane matthew
it's a five foot of water in here you
know
well that was insane i've never ever
seen it that high
that's the latest satellite image of
hurricane dorian
by 8
tomorrow
it'll be
in north carolina and by 8 a.m friday
morning
it'll be on top of us
yeah i don't know it doesn't look very
good be honest with you
further north in the port of wilmington
cargo vessel ice ranger is due to leave
for florida
with dorian in their path and coming
this way they've made a bold plan to
skirt around the storm leaving port
ahead of dorian's arrival
they'll pass within 80 nautical miles of
the eye
on their course for port canaveral
florida
taking command for the two-day voyage
ukrainian captain zakar zemlyakov
i am very proud of it
i was promoted
just
five days ago
the old responsibility now on my
shoulders yeah
a little bit scared
but i have to experience crew
passing this close to dorian's eye
zakhar expects to face large swells
this type of cargo is concentrated juicy
it's a very heavy box about 1.6 metric
tons
when the ship is uh moving walking
the cargo could shift to one side
well it would be dangerous for us
we're looking at some flooding from what
they're saying
there'll be a foot of water in that
house right there
in hatteras mandatory evacuation of the
island has begun
it can be that drastic that the the
storm wipes out the road so bad that it
takes weeks even months to repair
sometimes
[Music]
so kelsey and i we made a decision that
we are going to stay
because we want to be here for our
fishermen and we want to be here and be
able to recover everything we can as
fast as we can
there's the official warning
right there
hurricane warning in this area
pretty much telling you that if you
haven't
made plans to get out of here it's
probably time to do it
yep i'm here this is happening you know
there's no going back this is what we're
doing
september 5th
2019
at my house
ready to go
bring what you got dorian
a lot of people left
we're here for now whoa did you see that
on the outer banks fishing crews keep
our cameras running as they head ashore
to take care of their property
yeah definitely picking up here
it is what it is
as hurricane dorian prowls the eastern
seaboard
gps data shows vessels steering clear of
its vast wind field
but ice ranger continues on its course
into dorian's storm force winds
introduce yourself please my name is
valerie
second officer of motor vessel s ranger
i'm a city officer right now now we are
receiving in massage see this
signal
it's all about dorian
very
scared storm
for every 10 miles they burn over a ton
of fuel
but taking the shortest route must be
balanced against the safety of the ship
so in this weather it's difficult
even walking walking through the deck
the wind is very strong
the planned route requires the crew to
be on high alert
ready to respond to any change in
dorian's trajectory or power
of course nobody sleep
this night
you can't even drink the coffee
no more coffee no more tea
just only
keep the watch
hurricane dorian is moments from making
a direct hit on hatteras north carolina
its first and only u.s landfall
it's happening
seven o'clock
september six friday morning we are
almost in the eye
you can see it right there the whole
storm
and so
it begins
the power just went out
right now
and then the internet goes out and then
your phone service goes out and then
you're like okay now i'm really trapped
because you're not only physically
trapped now you're
virtually trapped as well
what you gonna do
as the eye is approaching you're getting
that inner eye wall most powerful winds
and driving rain
and it's gusting to about 100 miles an
hour and um
pretty wild here in the shingles go
you know come off your roof
and you can see
it's just spoiled really really hard
as you get through that eye wall
you can see it from a distance the light
changes
it goes from being very dark to being
lighter lighter
and then it goes like
dead calm silent
uh officially
officially in the eye look at the flag
wow
if we're in the eye
the birds come out and they fly to
wherever they think is going to be safe
animals
kind of come out of there hiding where
they were
and all of us come out and explore and
see like you know wow we're in the
middle of this
it's very strange it's very eerie it
gives me the chills just thinking about
it
hatteras is the most hurricane-prone
city in the u.s
but even here being in the eye is an
extraordinary event
hey
i had to give a look i couldn't take it
i had to go
there was literally six inches of water
in the bottom of the creek still
draining out towards the sound
i mean you don't see it this low
sometimes you see the bank over there
but
not all this exposed here
when all that water gets sucked out on
the southeast wind and then
as soon as we get that shift and that's
northwest eye wall comes it pushes all
the water back it comes all at once like
a wall of water next thing you know
there you
it's time to go back inside all right
bye guys
the eye is surrounded by a band of the
storm's most violent winds following
just minutes behind
yeah
that's all rain water rushing
back into this island
i could see the front coming
i barely get to the house and it starts
blowing hard again and raining
all right
rain started getting really heavy
look that water's coming up so fast
let's go
this is motor vessel ice ranger
and now
we are
passing very closely
[Music]
ice ranger is at the most critical part
of its journey passing within 70 miles
of hurricane dorian's eye
we have a captain
on the bridge he's come to alter the
course
to starboard
their plan is to change direction
cutting through dorian's wake to make
for port
now we have a swell 6.5 meters
and a significant wave
7.9 meters
in heavy seas the cargo in ice rangers
hold is at risk of breaking free of its
bindings causing a shift in weight that
would leave her gravely unstable
check it out guys
37 degrees
to starboard
in the 25 foot swells the rolling motion
is at the ship's safe limit
is
fighting against the strong wind and
waves the ice ranger's top speed is
reduced by more than half
diverting around dorian
has added a day to the journey
yeah this is the back side of the
eyeball
the other side of the hurricane
this is the flooding side
yeah this is about to get real
this is what we got
it
it's flooding
in my backyard there's been waves
pretty gnarly in hatteras dorian's
category one winds have pushed a seven
foot wall of water on shore
a tsunami-like storm surge is ripping
through north carolina's outer banks
honestly right now the worst thing is
things floating into your house and
taking down the structure that's there
wow look at it pretty good rushing right
there
eagle pass river
[Music]
just hoping the wind falls out soon
we were getting messages from friends
and people saying it was the worst
they'd ever seen
there's a coast guard right there
flying around checking on everybody
[Applause]
it's friday september 6. it's finally
going down
as far as i know
everyone's safe and haters
we're safe
dorian's passage over hatteras lasted
four hours
even more devastating than its 90 mile
per hour winds
was the seven foot storm surge that
swept across the island
it buckled the walls right here
wow
there was a lot of force coming through
here for sure
all said and done we lost thousands of
dollars of frozen fish product
and we had thousands of dollars of
damage to our business
holy
[Music]
that part of the wall is gone
all right
we're in
[Music]
you're looking at the damages and you're
saying to yourself you know well well
that sucks but all that can be replaced
you know
we're pretty fortunate considering how
bad it could have been
[Music]
compared to what happened in the bahamas
we've lost you know
nothing pretty much
cape hatteras was the only point in the
u.s where dorian made landfall
days later the aiken brothers were back
in business
ice ranger arrived safely in port
canaveral under the skilled guidance of
its new captain
in the bahamas
hurricane dorian was the island's worst
ever natural disaster
this catastrophic assault lasted 27
hours the most prolonged battering by an
atlantic hurricane of any populated
place in recorded history
[Music]
you